also den demografischen wandel könne
nicht aufhalten aber wir müssen uns ihr
stellen also uns fehlen kinder an allen
ecken und enden haben zu wenig kinder um
die rente zu finanzieren wir haben zu
wenig kinder um die gesundheit zu
finanzieren und dann haben wir noch die
pflegeversicherung in meinen augen das
schwerst zu finanzierende problem was
auf uns zukommt und das gemeinste wenn
ich so ausdrücken darf ist dass wir
wissen dass dieses problem also wir
wissen es seit über 30 jahren das ist
auch an zukommt wir sind sehenden augen
sin ja in dieser situation gelaufen wir
haben wahlgeschenke gemacht wir haben
rentenerhöhungen durchgesetzt und jetzt
stehen wir vor einem großen
scherbenhaufen davon will ich noch nicht
sprechen aber wir stehen unter druck wir
müssen was tun wir müssen an unseren
sozialversicherungssystemen
arbeiten wir müssen reformen bringen
damit es in zukunft noch gut wird
ja also erstmal möchte ich sagen dass
diejenigen die jahrelang oder jahrzehnte
lang hart gearbeitet haben die müssen
auch im alter gut leben können und
deswegen auch eine auskömmliche rente
bekommen aber ich sehe auch mit großer
sorge dass der generationenvertrag immer
mehr bröckelt und eigentlich neu
aufgesetzt werden muss das liegt an
unterschiedlichen faktoren die menschen
werden glücklicherweise immer älter
bleiben immer länger gesund und
gleichzeitig das haben sie eben völlig
zu recht gesagt also in der partei
übergreifend einer meinung gibt es
leider zu wenig kinder und zu wenige
arbeitnehmer die die vielen rentner in
deutschland oder die vielen renten in
deutschland dann bezahlen können und
deswegen brauchen wir
generationenübergreifende reform wobei
mir immer auch ein punkt ganz wichtig
ist das würde ich auch ganz zu beginn
einmal sagen weil ja einige immer eine
debatte anführen denk mal an den
dachdecker an den möbelpacker und an
diejenigen die wirklich hart schuften
finde ich völlig richtig die auch in der
debatte nach vorne zu stellen und dass
die natürlich nicht mit 70 oder 75 hat
körperliche arbeit machen aber die sehr
viele die zum beispiel auch ein bürojob
haben und die fit sind die wollen auch
länger arbeiten also wir haben ja eine
so fit
generation der 70-jährigen wie noch nie
zuvor in der geschichte und deswegen
glaube ich müssen wir langfristig die
durchschnittliche lebenserwartung an die
durchschnittliche lebensarbeitszeit
koppeln zu einem generationen
übergreifenden
mechanismus kommen denn viele andere
europäische länder längst eingeführt
haben erschlossen da würde ich mir
wünschen dass wir vielleicht sogar ein
parteiübergreifenden konsens hinbekommen
ich bin leider das muss ich auch noch
einmal sagen etwas enttäuscht von der
fdp weil ich in der letzten
legislaturperiode auch jetzt auch selber
in als cdu ja gesagt hat da die fdp
viele richtige ansätze die hat den mut
gehabt debatten anzustoßen und jetzt in
der andere koalition wird nichts
umgesetzt der einzig sinnvolle vorschlag
nämlich eine aktion rent einzuführen ist
jetzt auch noch kassiert worden die
kommende jahr kann man bisher leider
noch nichts davon wissen müssen wir an
zusagen bekommen
und deswegen muss ich sagen da hat die
ampel koalition bisher versagt ich kann
sagen wir wenn die cdu da druck machen
dass diese reform auch durchgeführt
werden in dieser legislaturperiode als
ein wasser mal so sagen die rente ist
ein schneeballsystem geworden im grunde
nach dem motto wer zuletzt kommt nix der
gelackmeierte also wenn ich meinen
rentenbescheid öffnet er kommt ja alle
paar monate mal dann denke ich mir naja
ich werde alle paar monate komme die
nächste möglicherweise auch von anderen
leuten also eine kommt da einmal ja aber
wenn irgendwas tun dass irgendwann der
sebastian gleich los dann denke ich
irgendwie mensch na ja da muss ich also
von meinem jetzigen lebensstandard der
suche und rufen eigentlich ist ich lebe
nicht verschwenderisch müsste ich schon
spürbar unter und dann ist muss ist das
ja aber ein betrag der wirksam wird im
jahr in meinem fall 2004 50 oder so wo
ich mich frage was ist denn das dann
eigentlich noch wert dieser betrag
schnitt von inflation und steuern und
steuern ging ja auch noch ein jahr das
problem bei solchen reformen ist ja
immer dass die leute wieder gewählt
werden möchten und dass reformen die
schmerzhaft sind in der regel nicht zu
prozentualen zuwächsen bei den nächsten
wahlen führen das ist deswegen ist die
sache so schwer zu machen die analyse
dateien ja glaube ich alle ich glaube es
wenn andere parteien am tisch säßen
würden die auch das gleich gesagt nur
wie macht man es also was sicher eine
einen beitrag dazu wäre wäre ist
die beschäftigung von älteren
arbeitnehmern die arbeiten möchten zu
erleichtern und arbeitgeber zu
motivieren die leute weiter arbeiten zu
lassen das ist glaube ich etwas was
relativ leicht umzusetzen muss man da
gesellschaftlich auch um dinge auch er
sollte ja und dann werde die leute ist
man bei 50 schon zu alt und wird
irgendwie aufs altenteil irgendwie
rausgedrängt abfindung unterstützt da
muss man vielleicht als gesellschafter
aber das findet aber schon automatisch
statt weil einfach ist ein enorm
fachkräftemangel gibt das heißt da sind
die unternehmen gezwungen ich will aber
allen auch vielleicht mal auch in der
politik mut machen doch auch diese
debatten zu führen weil ich glaube das
ist ein irrglaube zu sagen na ja die
älteren die denken nur an sich und sagen
nach mir die sintflut ganz viele die
haben ja selber kinder oder enkelkinder
und den ist auch wichtig dass es den
kindern und enkelkindern gut geht und
wenn wir sagen wir wollen das
generationenübergreifend gerecht und
fair aufziehen und auch die lasten
zwischen den generationen gerecht
verteilen dann gibt es glaube ich dafür
auch deutlich mehr zustimmung und dann
wird man daraus auch nicht ein kampf
zwischen den generationen machen den ja
eigentlich niemand will ich glaube sie
wissen als junger cdu abgeordneter genau
wie schwer ist es auch in ihrer eigenen
partei mit dem was sie sagen richtig
durchzudringen wenn ich mich an die
letzten wettkämpfe auch der union
erinnere dann war das dürfte das nie ein
renten wahlkampf sein weil man genau vor
dem angst hatte dass es heißt ja dass
herr hirsch weder des
renteneintrittsalters gab den
wissenschaften dienst des
bundeswirtschaftsministers damals peter
altmaier der vier oder fünf monate vor
der bundestagswahl im letzten jahr
gesagt ja wir müssen das red tritt das
renteneintrittsalter deutlich noch mal
wieder erhöhen und das wurde direkt von
peter altmaier zurückgewiesen nein da
sind unabhängige wissenschaftliche ein
nichts damit zu tun und damit war das
thema aus seiner sicht wieder ad acta
gelegt aber ich glaube es geht ihnen ja
vor affichen gleich um das thema rente
und mich wird dann schon interessiert ob
unsere zuschauerinnen und zuschauer auch
was meinen sie eigentlich mit
sozialreformen das was passieren muss
das hören wir immer wieder aber was
konkret muss endlich passieren als wären
wir auch diesen glücklichen zustand dass
wir immer älter werden also wir haben
eine lebenserwartung also ich sowieso
schon bin glaube ich bei 89 und meine
kinder sind schon über 90 besonders die
tochter und noch vor kurzem noch nicht
vor so langer zeit da ist man halt nicht
so alt geworden und wenn man mit 60 dann
kann man halt mit 70 nicht ein
schlaganfallpatient
werden und mit 90 kein demenz fall und
diese zahlen der also die prognosen über
die anzahl der dementen die wir in
zukunft haben werden ist
unfassbar also das kann man sich nicht
vorstellen was da auf uns zukommt weil
sie können ihren dementen nicht bedeute
dass andere brauchen eine
eins-zu-eins-betreuung wir stehen doch
jetzt schon über mangelnde pflegekräfte
wie soll das gehen ja wie soll die
reform aussehen da haben wir also ich
hab natürlich vorschläge dazu was man
sie die mal raus ich bin ja ich lebe ja
die eigenverantwortung sei es bei corona
bei der gesundheitsvorsorge da bin ich
auch dafür dass man sich also dass man
eigenen anteil zahlt und bei der
pflegeversicherung könnte ich mir
durchaus eine karenzzeit vorstellen kann
die spd mit macht carlsson hat was sagen
sie einmal ganz karenzzeit hat meinen
sie was genau ist man vielleicht so wie
es früher war dass die familie für den
zu pflegenden aufkommt so lange sie sich
das leisten können also nicht das
erbschafts bewegungsprogramm was wir
dank der cdu bekommen haben sondern dass
man sagt das erste jahr dass ein mensch
in pflege kommt das bezahlt man sei also
die kinder quasi
genau wie
haben sie diese vielleicht zurück er
wird ja die pflege endet ja mit dem wenn
sie dann den koalitionsvertrag an schon
das ganze kapitel wo es um das thema
rente geht gesetzliche
krankenversicherungen wo es um das thema
pflege geht da muss ihn ja eigentlich
dann gerade auch mit dem vorschuss sind
sie gerade gemacht haben es kalt über
den rücken laufen das ist ja ein
programm er für deutlich mehr ausgaben
und damit auch deutlich höhere beiträge
also von dem was sie fordern ist ja die
koalition in der sie ja auch mit dabei
sind auch komplett anderen weg quasi
sind die geisterfahrerin oder
geisterfahrerin will ich nicht sagen
aber ich bin nur die analysen die ganz
reichen klang ja ja und deren ziel ist
auch ist später mal kinder zu haben und
es einfach eine klare rechnung ich finde
es einfach
ich finde es einfach ungerecht den
zukünftigen generationen das zu
überlassen und nicht die in die nicht zu
nehmen die uns das problem beschert
haben nämlich die die keine kinder
gezeugt haben also so das hört sich
jetzt krass an aber es ist ja nun mal so
die kinder sind nicht die verursacher
des problems ist ein anderer in das man
ein bisschen ausgleich schafft und dass
die mit in die verantwortung gezogen
werden das ist bei der rente vielleicht
dass man man ja länger arbeitet wo man
ja fast 30 jahre also der
durchschnittsrente rentner geht mit 61
in die rente und wird 90 jahre alt also
bezieht ja auch 30 jahre rente das ist
ein ganz natürliches recht wenn man wird
bezieht die frauen beziehen im schnitt
20 jahre rente und die männer beziehen
glaube ich im schnitt 15 jahre rente
also und ist ja die marine schon bei
beiden zwei jahre die frauen 20
aber ich will noch mal ein paar zahlen
also was sie eben formuliert haben hat
ja viele vernünftige aspekte aber
leider das aber wenn wir jetzt hier ein
sozialdemokraten sitzen hätten dann
würde ja genau das gegenteil sie haben
sie in ihrer partner ja auch das heißt
dass die abdecken würden dann merkt man
wer die ampelkoalition die weiß nicht
wohin steuert so und was ich erwarte ist
das natürlich bei allen unterschieden
die eine koalition immer hat man sich
jetzt wirklich auf einen vernünftigen
kompromiss verständigt und da wirklich
auch reformen durchgeführt werden weil
ansonsten passiert nichts und wir können
uns das nicht länger erlauben ich habe
selber auch in der letzten
legislaturperiode da druck gemacht war
auch mit meiner eigenen partei nicht
immer zufrieden sage ich auch ganz klar
und deswegen würde ich mir wünschen dass
wir da vielleicht sogar
parteiübergreifenden konsens hinbekommen
nur die ampel ist der wirkliche
enttäuschung da steht oben fortschritts
koalition drauf aber es ist eher ein
rückschritt koalition sie haben das wort
hat fdp dabei ist ja und das wir
diskutieren und reformieren also weil
man ja nix immer mehr schuldig jetzt
wenn wir das jetzt einmal abgreifen und
beschließen und zu ende denken und da
will ich ihn gleich zu nahe treten aber
den letzten 16 jahren gab es eine
bundeskanzlerin die ihrer partei
angehört und wir reden über einen
ausufernden sozialstaat deswegen glaube
ich weiß ich nicht ob die cdu gerade der
beste kronzeuge ist um anzuprangern dass
die ampel jetzt seit 15 monaten
dabei ist gewisse dinge vielleicht
falsch zu machen er ist in große
koalition hat wichtige rentenreform
durchgeführt